John Leonard where did you get the title
lonesome Rangers for your book well it
showed up in one of the essays that I
that I had written and I found that I
was spending so much time thinking about
thinkers who were somehow disenchanted
there disaffiliated or dispossessed and
wandering either their own intellectual
frontier or often some Stepfather land
somewhere and I just thought lonesome
Rangers they think so much about so much
but have no home and it seemed resonant
any of this autobiographical a lonesome
Ranger is that you well I'm not I'm not
a sad case and that's in that sense I do
feel perhaps like many adopted New
Yorkers that I never belonged anywhere
else
and you can't be you know I was born
here in Washington DC I grew up mostly
in California when I arrived in New York
in 1967 it's finally seen that I'd come
to a place where everybody was moving at
my speed and that made me happy because
I always felt that everybody had been
slow motion most of my life but you
can't ever be said to be home in a
restful sense in a city like New York
and and I've never I've never been able
to settle in professionally either it's
well books are my first love
I've reviewed television and movies and
write social commentary and and I don't
think I would be happy doing any one of
those things that the combination the
combination keeps me of seems to be now
the normal respiration of my
intelligence and keeps me going but it's
not serene it's not restful how many
years with the New York Times is a book
reviewer I was 16 years at the New York
Times and and most of those were as a as
a reviewer under my own byline five of
them I was the editor of the Sunday book
review section and that was in the
middle and I discovered that the logic
and newspaper careers
is that you make your reputation with
your byline and then if you advance at
the newspaper it's an identity really
and it's a perfectly decent logic it's
just that some of us are not editors
some of us are not corporate people at
all some of us do not cannot worry about
budgets and even personnel problems and
you I I was still young enough after
five years of being an editor to say but
I'm not writing I've lost all the music
in my life all of all the bouncing of
words together that make me happy
I've got to get out and I could what
year did you leave the New York Times
I left the New York Times the end of
1982 what year did you join CBS 1988
shortly before the election in between I
did well I for years written television
criticism for New York magazine it's a
very friendly place for me for a long
time almost 20 years but in between
major news organizations like the New
York Times and CBS I I renew books for
National Public Radio fresh air every
week I wrote a column for New York
Newsday when there was a New York
version of Newsday until the Los Angeles
Times serial people killed it wrote a
weekly column there and I wrote essays
for the literary essays for the nation
so if you picked this book up and had to
write a review of it for the New York
Times what would you say about your own
book what would you say about your style
I would say that the style has always is
now and always has been a little too
fancy a little too in love with itself a
little too Jetstream paper trail a
little too given to to to list that that
that bounced off the items of which
bounce off one another a little - given
to
to intellectual name-dropping with the
hope that it will that it will be a
shortcut to something that I don't have
to explain to a reader these are the
these are the excesses I would hope that
the kindness of such a reviewer would be
that there is music in the prose that
there is a basic generosity toward what
other people are trying to do in the
arts that there is a genuine enthusiasm
for for interesting ideas for ambitious
endeavours and that there is a joy in in
the life of the mind who was Lester
Markel and why do you write about
Lester Markel was the Westermarck L
invented the sunday New York Times as as
we all now know it in other words he
invented all of those sections the Week
in Review the magazine the the
standalone book review section the
Travel section the this entire empire
the the New York Times is to be divided
under the publisher there was a Sunday
paper and there was a daily paper and
they were not edited by the same people
and they were largely not written by the
same people marquel ran the sunday
fiefdom and he ran it with a what the
dictatorial hand I never worked for him
he had been forced into retirement
shortly before I arrived at the New York
Times in 1967 because anybody who
creates I'm imagining this because I
don't know but anybody who creates
something from the ground up and feels
proprietary about it
and loses power is going to be resented
by those he injured who are now who have
now taken over all the sections so by
the time I became in 1971 the editor of
The Sunday Book Review
Lester Markel who was still a vital man
and his approaching I guess seventy at
that time maybe a little older um had no
place to sit no place to visit in the
sunday New York Times he was not welcome
in anybody's office except mine because
he had done me no injury and we used to
sit and I used to listen to the war
stories and how he used to do it and all
of this and this was fine I've always
enjoyed this and you learn a lot and
it's no spit I lose no body heat but
then we got into as I described in this
book of difficult and queasy making edge
of what scrupulous journalistically and
and that is he was writing a book he was
writing a book about his career in
journalism and what he had and what he
thought the lessons were of that career
he was having a little difficulty
finding a publisher for that book I
decided to help out which is again
ambiguous behavior on the part of the
editor in the Sunday Book Review that's
a powerful job but so when I'm calling
publishers to see if they'd be
interested in something it's not a an
innocent call and it can't be perceived
as innocent but I did and and we did
achieve a worthy dignified essentially
nonprofit publisher for Mark Ellis book
and then I don't know if you want me to
go on with the details of this but it's
a it's a it's a strange world but book
reviewing and when at last
Mark Ellis book was published I had the
the complicated decision of sending it
out for a review and and I needed
somebody who would be
uncorrupted by the New York Times
uncorrupted by a germ Alice or
friendship who would be fair to the book
of positively and negatively and the the
person I found was been bagged icky and
who was then a professor of journalism
but between bag Dickey and writing his
review for me and and the assignment of
that review he went to work for the
Washington Post and then Bradley at the
Washington Post had a policy that nobody
at the post could write for The Times
The Times said policy that nobody at the
Times could write to the post it was
Kindergarten I said this assignment
happened before you know came we'd be
men about this I'm in a bind and we went
back and forth and until I had to make a
deal that I would review the book of
Benjamin Bradley's choice for the
Washington Post if he allowed back
Dickey in to review the Lester Markel
book for me and he that was yet to be
determined in the future that would be
determined and and a couple of years
later it was determined I was asked to
review Sally Quinn's memoir of her days
at CBS for the Washington Post and I
thought this to be outrageous and I
refused and ever since I have tried to
explain to people who seem to think that
this is not very important or not very
rinky dink or inky dink on its level
it's not a moral issue but it is a moral
issue and I don't know how to explain it
except that except that when the people
at the top have basic a basic contempt
for the night for the moral niceties or
the ambiguities of who should be
reviewing books and why they should be
reviewing them then that's going to
drift all the way down it's going to
corrupt the process and we're going to
end up where we have ended up in this
country now where everything is reviewed
according to its budget that determines
the news and we don't believe anybody
anymore we don't we don't believe the
editorial judgment that says this book
this movie this television program
the most important thing this week that
has been determined by forces beyond
disinterested criticism it's been
determined by by by competing with the
other fellow it's been determined by the
amount of the advertising budget it's
been determined by who owns you in the
ultimate corporate structure and
therefore the the very signals of the
culture that we depend to sort out sixty
thousand new books every year all those
television programs every year how do we
make people pay attention to the ones we
care about if people cease to believe us
and they have then we become one more
blog on the Internet you know one more
opinion and we could be a good opinion
it could be a bad opinion but nobody
knows because we're no longer trusted
why we're no longer trusted because
we've abused our function and we've
allowed we've allowed ourselves to buy
into it I I can say now I've been 14
years at CBS I used to be very proud of
what I did
it was unusual because I was interested
in unusual things I'm now embarrassed by
some of the things that I do and I'm
going to stop and and that's because
instead of discovering which is what I
think criticism is is mostly about is is
seeing and reading and experiencing as
much as you possibly can and say hey
this is good this is new this needs to
be talked about so that other people
will pay attention here's something
unusual here's something valuable the
board of wise be ignored instead of
discovering the new and books in the new
and television of the new I find that
I'm in a new competitive environment in
which nobody on television wants a
television critic on television because
you're going to be saying nice things
about the competition so they prefer you
not say anything all even about them
this is true throughout television there
is no decent television criticism on
television because they don't want to
give the competition a break that's gone
by the board
nobody wants an unusual book that
nobody's ever heard of
unless it's on c-span unless it's on the
weekend that's even better with the with
the whole of the whole books thing you
want only the books that are already the
best-selling books because those are the
books that everybody else is reading and
already talking about I mean I'm really
sad that Oprah is no longer recommending
books I think this is a great loss for
the culture but it's kind of inevitable
we're having fewer and fewer books
talked about and and those are the ones
that have the biggest advertising
budgets and those are the ones that go
into the hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of copies and I end up as a
critic for at least on CBS Sunday
morning doing nothing but going to
Hollywood movies and frankly I'm not
interested and what I had to say about
spider-man why should anybody else be
interested and I'm only reviewing
spider-man because it's the movie of the
week and everybody else is reviewing it
and if I didn't review it I wouldn't be
competing with the sunday supplements
with the other magazines so I end up
revering spider-man I end up reviewing
Star Wars attack of the clothes you know
I end up reviewing 8-millimeter I end up
reviewing movies I wouldn't go to on my
own and and that is what the culture has
become it's become a competition of loud
noises that determine the journalistic
agenda the cultural journalistic agenda
about which we opinion eyes and we are
paid I've always been paid and I've
always been well paid on because of the
very Jetstream style that that I would
criticize myself for my stylistic tricks
I make some noise and some firecrackers
and some pyrotechnics and my opinion
almost doesn't matter so long as my
amusement value stays stays high but
inside there's a decay there is a decay
that that you notice that you say I'm
not doing what I ought to be
and and Barnett is a function of getting
old I'm 63 years old I've been doing
this a long time I've had many many many
opinions on many many many subjects but
that's not the way I feel if say the New
York Review of Books asks me to to read
all of Richard powers and I'd read only
a couple of his novels and then write at
whatever length I want about what I
found there and then I did then I
rediscover why why did this they begin
with why I cared so much about it
because here was somebody who was really
really smart and who could who not only
deserved but could sustain however close
attention was brought to his work and
this is so this is a this is what
criticism used to mean to me and and and
what I intend to go out with it
meaning to me you said you weren't going
to do this anymore when do you plan on
hanging up well we know we go back and
forth and back and forth I'm in the last
year of a contract with CBS and you know
maybe we'll revise the terms of what
gets done but but I don't see it that
way
and I'm not really blaming them I mean
this is I have no place to go to do what
it is I want to do the environment
itself has changed around me and maybe
it was a bizarre thing for this kind of
criticism to be part of a program to
begin with when shad Noel started CBS
Sunday morning Jeff Greenfield was it
was hired it was the first one hired to
do the job that I later got and it was
specifically to review television
television that he liked and it didn't
matter if it was on ABC or NBC or or CNN
or wherever see any wasn't there at that
time but um and then he was succeeded by
Ron powers and then I came along and
I've been there
a very long time but as I say at some
point in the competitive the competitive
thing probably at the point that the
that Fox stole a whole bunch of
affiliates from CBS along with along
with the professional football CBS
certainly stopped wanting to hear me say
there was something nice to watch on on
Fox and and and this is this is this
kind of consideration and this kind of
resentment in this kind of competitive
drawing in and closing off and squeezing
down it's true across the board
you know I'm hardly saying that CBS is
the is the single guilty party here it's
they're all they're all the same
you start out very early writing for the
National Review Bill Buckley's
publication and today you write for the
nation yep could you possibly have gone
from you know a farther way and you're
thinking well uh the thinking wasn't so
far you have to I grew up in California
where as a Long Beach California as a
and you know my mother was a was active
in the Democratic Party you know I was a
California liberal I was the president
of Long Beach young Democrats in high
school but when I was hired by Buckley
in in 1959 I was a college dropout I was
working nights for United Press writing
captions for photographs with the with a
Tuesday Wednesday weekend that for 47.56
a week
Buckley saw an article of mine about
Gran chillage in a sort of throwaway
magazine no longer exists and Buckley
was hiring young writers with style it
helped that I had an Irish name and that
I've been on the Harvard Crimson these
were these were credentials that he
could see and that I had this that I was
making fun of Branchville it but the
fact of the matter is
that these are the people that Buckley
hired in the late 50s as the magazine
was just three or four years off the
ground
he hired Garry wills who was a genuine
conservative and who was radicalized by
the civil rights movement and then
Vietnam he hired Joan Didion who was
certainly gone off the reservation so
far as American foreign policy is
concerned on social issues at home she
might still be called conservative but
he hired Renata Adler
he hired Harley encroaching he was
hiring people without regard to their
politics and he was sure that the
charismatic sub his own personality
would take care of their of their
politics and and he was to me he was
offering $100 a week to learn the
magazine business from the ground up I
mean I took the stuff to the printer and
you know I did I did all with all the
little things there in a small magazine
teach you the business and when I told
him when he offered me this job was
flabbergasted and I said I think I have
to discuss it with my fiancee and he
said where is she and I said well she's
a senior at Radcliffe and he said tell
her it's the New Republic which then was
a liberal and I was sold because that
was you know that was the sense of humor
if he had a sense of humor I could
certainly find out what this was like
and I had a very good time I met
Whittaker Chambers but I met James
Burnham on that Willmar Kendall you know
the many of the Giants of the American
right which served me very well much
later on when I went to the New York
Times it served me when Harrison
Salisbury started the op-ed page of The
Times they came to me to say who are the
litter right-wingers who should we get
writing to the op-ed page the new
outdated page of The Times and it served
me at the Times Book Review in finding
reviewers who weren't from the same
place people like guy Davenport there
were wonderful reviewers but whose
politics were outside certainly or
outside the liberal mainstream and
Buckley remains a very good friend and
Victor Navasky is a friend equally as
all going going way back and Victor
gossip in the nation from the nation and
so
that's you know the politics there have
always been more more congenial but
Buckley is still as Murray Kempton the
late Murray Kempton once said that the
only one phone call to make from jail it
would be to build Buckley and that's the
one you would trust to get you out of
jail and I feel that too the gift for
friendship was was extraordinary I mean
he helped he helped get me hired at the
New York Times when he was sure they
wouldn't because I'd once worked for him
so he dug up an article I'd written for
Victor Navasky making fun of my working
for National Review so that the times
could be sure that I wasn't a right-wing
frother at the mouth this is for very
this is a gift of friendship in this
book you have a bunch of articles that I
guess have been written in other places
yeah for other places New York Review of
Books New York Times Book Review Newsday
tikkun yep just one particular and what
is it
tikkun is the is the the Jewish
intellectual answer to commentary cocoon
is the left-wing commentary cocoon is
peace now when commentary is laocoon and
so far as Israeli politics would be
concerned the editor of Taccone even now
is is agitating on on on behalf of
palestinian statehood not perhaps this
controversial way though as it is at the
moment but they asked me to review
robert stones novel about jerusalem in
which oddly enough the concept of
takumin which is a religious jewish
Judaic religious concept figures largely
and I'd written at length about Robert
stone elsewhere so this was a natural
natural thing for them to do it did for
a while there though I
wondered about for a while there I was
invited to every conference of American
Jewish intellectuals to think about
Israel and then and I thought well I've
come a long way for a lapsed Catholic
but you live in the New York literary
world for long enough and you become an
honorary Jewish intellectual it was fun
but you also had one in salon.com and I
believe don't you have a relative work
there my son is the business and
technology editor of salon we are all
hoping that it survives it was certainly
been a casualty of the of the the.com
bust and and they certainly live
hand-to-mouth with a very stripped-down
staff but they produce something that is
to me genuinely interesting and and they
and they passed the test of any magazine
whatever form it arrives in your head in
is that they gave us a whole bunch of
new writers that I hadn't seen before
and have come to trust and depend on and
check in on and they've created a weird
kind of daily newspaper magazine and I
and I'm my heart goes out to them
because they're as they've had
successive purges of the staff in order
to cut expenses everybody has had to
work harder and harder and harder and
Laura Miller who's there New York editor
but also handles though all the book
section you know now is writing most of
the book section as well as everything
else he does and I can just I can see
the frazzle but and I can hear it in my
son's voice Andrew when I talk to it on
the other hand you may have had this
experience I only had it once in our
professional lives if we're extremely
lucky there will be a period
when we are working with colleagues who
were roughly our age they have our same
interests they're dedicated the same
missionary zeal for whatever it is
whatever journalistic purpose or other
purpose it is maybe we're excited about
creating something new defining our own
terms
seeing what happens playing with the
changing it seeing it grow seeing people
respond we tend to assume if we're in
the middle of that happy small group of
people doing something we care about
doing it as well as we think we can we
tend to assume that that will repeat
itself the rest of our lives this is
what work ought to be like after all
ought to be that satisfying that
collegial and then we discovered that
never again is it for some lucky reason
there was a time when I became the
editor of the book review most of the
editors were roughly my age the previous
editor had been there 27 years and we
all had changes that we thought the
magazine desperately needed to make we
were all on each other's side we made
those changes we had an enormous amount
of fun we learned a lot we made mistakes
and then gradually all these people were
hired for better jobs and they
disappeared you woke up woke up one day
and said that community is gone but
there'll be other communities there
wasn't not for me for Andrew for my son
Andrew and the people at salon there may
be other jobs and there may be other
collegial experiences but right now this
one absorbs everything they've got and I
love it and they'll go down with the
ship and they may never be so lucky
again to mention before we start you
have a daughter
Georgetown teaching yes yes I just took
kids in the family yes I have a
stepdaughter in New York who has been
working for the coalition to the
homeless that's for my second she's for
my second marriage but yes my two
children
aimée ism is the scholar of the family
and she's amazing she this was a kid who
in high school wrote all over papers on
Jim Morrison of the doors and she was a
roadie in a rock band
she seemed to have very little
overarching intellectual curiosity but
she went to Barnard and every course she
took exploded in her mind I taught at
Columbia during the four years she was
advised oh that I could see her for
dinner every Monday night when I'd go in
for a seminar course and I watched this
happen you know I watched this kid who
watched television and listened to rock
and roll become an intellectual and be
adopted by the history department at at
Barnard College they loved her and they
gave her the history prize and then she
went to Wisconsin for an MA and then she
went to Berkeley for her PhD and then
she came out of Berkeley and she went
around and she was interviewed at
Georgetown and you know how difficult
jobs in the humanities are right now for
a young person and but she she had her
PhD and she had apparently a great gift
for teaching I'm not seen her teach I've
only heard a better teaching and they
hired her and she's just she's ecstatic
she's she's in the middle of a vital
University and and she teaches and she
reads and she researches and she she
writes and and I look at that and say
somebody is somebody's one Leonard has
become respectable now I want to talk
about your writing stuff yeah we talked
about it briefly earlier and I had to do
that I've gone to a chapter why
socialism never happened here yeah where
is that what's this from where was it
originally originally appeared that
appeared in salon how do you say in
salon was posted on salon or whatever
the terms are so it was a was on the on
the worldwide web what moved you to
write this well they asked me
at this subject they asked me to review
the book I had revealed a couple I'd
reviewed a futurist and and I grew
viewed Robert plans putnams book on
Bowling Alone
these are the kinds of books so long as
it was asking me to review the kinds of
books but nobody else asked me to review
sort of political political books I
could review them for the nation but the
nation has lots of people to review
those kinds of books and everybody else
asked me to review literary books um so
I was I was pleased and I was asked
because I you know I would have
described myself you know as well how to
put this the the other day or a while
ago there was an article in The New York
Times about Nadine Gordimer in South
Africa and she and she refused to
describe herself as a liberal she said
no I'm a leftist I'm a leftist and that
reminded me that some years ago on a
public television conversation Susan
Sontag and a deed Gordimer we're talking
about all kinds of things and Susan
Sontag said well the old categories of
left and right don't mean anything
anymore
wouldn't you agree Nadine and Nadine
Gordimer looked at her and smiled in the
way that she has and then she said well
I don't know Susan but I think I still
agree with jean-paul Sartre socialism is
the horizon of the world I sitting this
late at night pyrotechnician
okay socialism is the horizon all the
awful things that we know about the
Soviet Union all of all the feelings
that we have those of us who would say
were on the left that socialists have
never having really been tried outside
of a few Scandinavian initiatives that
to describe it as as the horizon of the
world seems so impossibly nostalgic
almost 19th century but it also
describes something which is unreachable
it describes something that is that is
new thickets and it's kind of a twilight
notion and without making fun of it
it reminds you it reminds me as good
thinking about this book that that
people a lot of the people who became
socialist and certainly a lot of the
American socialists among people I know
best decayed socialists for all the
right reasons
they became socialists because they
believed in social justice and in
economic justice and social and economic
justice and these are not things to be
despised no matter how the world changes
no matter how many Tyurin Dome at ur how
many Pol Pot's no matter how many
Stalin's my hair that doesn't wipe out
the the kind of politics that would be
inspired by this kind of idealism is not
much different from my parenting when my
children are young I want the best for
them I want to organize around them I
want everything that they do in the way
they proceed in the world to be fair I
want their values to be decent I want
all of these things all of these things
were incorporated in in a political
platform over a series of years in the
American Socialist Party and then of
course there were the sectarian split
ups and there were all those things that
happened and while it isn't fair to say
the social has never happened anywhere
it is certainly fair to say it never
happened here and Seymour Martin Lipset
has been a scholar of these things and I
took a course of his out of Berkeley
when I was when I was much younger and I
thought let's try to think about it
let's try to think about it and in a
place like salon I don't have to be an
associate professor of European labor
movements in order to have an opinion on
why socialism didn't happen here you
know I can read the book and I can think
about it I can think about it on my own
before I read we will put it on the
screen so people get yeah
I know but dude but I just want to read
this this early part in the book it says
this book is published by the new press
and it says the new press was
established in 1990 as a not-for-profit
alternative to the large commercial
publishing houses currently dominating
the book publishing industry when I hear
you say you're wrote for salon.com or
write for them and then publish a new
press are we talking about somebody
doesn't make a lot of money on this
stuff oh yeah no the book you make you
make your my you make your money writing
about television for New York magazine
you make your money reviewing reviewing
spider-man for CBS you do not make your
money reviewing books about socialism
for salon nor do you make you give money
by collecting all those in a book
published by the new press but the new
press is run by by Andre schefren they
used to run Pantheon and was given the
golden parachute at Pantheon and all the
editors left when he was asked by the
Random House corporate Newhouse
corporate before Newhouse sold out the
Germans to reduce by two-thirds his his
list and it was a complicated and
ambitious intellectual list and he
refused and he was out so he got
foundation money and everything to start
the kind of publishing house that does a
lot of educational materials in the
Hebrides as well as published Studs
Terkel because he's Andres always
published done circle so when Andre
started that publishing house I thought
here's an honest place for me to go I
mean this is I'm not I'm not interested
in I don't need any more money I don't
want to vote you know I children are
successfully launched in the world but I
want a place where where where I can
bring books that they consist of the
best that I can do and that will that
will that will be distributed
distributed through Norton 2 to
bookstores where where readers come in
who were interested in this kind of
thing and some of these books see this
is the fourth of mine that Andre and a
new press published in some tube
than others the last one did quite well
because it looked like a tabloid but it
was the same essential contents but we
all nobody loses any money and this is
another whole whole story this is you
know the the fact of the matter is that
until the last decade maybe 15 years at
a stretch publishing in the United
States book publishing in the United
States would have would have averaged
over all the book publishing for 85
years or so would have averaged maybe a
four percent profit four percent the
people who went into publishing the way
the same as the people who went into
newspapers didn't go into it to make a
lot of money at other reasons and other
satisfactions in mind but we didn't
think about there was something wrong if
we didn't make 10% or 12% and now people
are being asked to go 17 24 30 percent
and the business school people are
coming in and you wonder why they do
something else why are they going into
the book business book publishers used
to be in business to publish the books
they wanted the publishing to make sure
they didn't lose money on them to keep
the process going and you can still
publish a book and not lose money you
can publish anything you want but you
can't ever ordained a best-seller that's
more complicated and and right now
newspapers magazines book publishers
everybody's got to have that twenty
percent or twenty four percent return on
investment to the quarterly stockholders
a dividend report and there's just those
papers were never in business to make
this kind of money so it happens
everybody gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and has bought out and it's
bought out with and with leveraged debt
and then people get fired because you've
got too much overhead and you're paying
off your debt and you keep raising the
amount of profit that you're supposed to
make and an economy which ought to go
back to socialism you'd think an economy
ought to be for the workers in
the economy take that part to be one of
the things that it's about the
well-being of the people who make up
your political economy and what it's not
that's not let me admit to you I'll
confess to you that in order to read
your book I had I would have liked have
had you in the room with me because I
could have asked you to define a lot of
these things but I had a dictionary next
to me to help me understand but I want I
want to put it on the screen and I want
to ask you to explain some of this
because this isn't your style
yeah India I heard you on Sunday morning
he sees the same style but let's start I
just picked this paragraph yeah page 241
I'll start to read it audience you can
see it on the screen the big picture is
that from the get-go our core values
glowed in the dark like the Three Mile
Island and ethos of individualism is it
a veldt Reshiram delta chung good
clothes of anti statism
what's anti stated what's a belter shop
Elton John's is a is a cultural spirit
it's a you know you throw in the German
to dazzle the credulous but it's a great
word Belton Chong and it's always it
always means what a whole culture seems
to feel and and and then takes as its as
its definition so it's but it's the it's
the world spirit of the culture and anti
statism certainly is is in the is wired
and the American genetic code it is a
suspicion of government on every level
but the bigger the bigger the government
the larger the suspicious this is going
to work well by interrupting all the
time I'll be catching base it and in a
blank check from God then I'll go on we
sprang full-blown from John Locke's
higher brow a natural-born hegemon
hegemony of bourgeois money-grubbers let
me just stop - yes ma'am well that's
that's contracting a lot one of the
after the after the after the horrors of
the the English revolution John Locke
and all the other gentlemen the
the of the English enlighten that got
together and decided this kind of thing
can never happen again and we've got to
we've got to write the sort of social
contract in which property is respected
and nobody ever goes to any extreme but
but property rights were were were
indispensable so you look at English
history from then on it was a very good
system for the people who already had
the money or the land for everybody else
the Commons kept getting smaller and
smaller and smaller which is why you had
so much trouble in the 19th century even
after the after the French Revolution at
the at the end of the 18th I just kind
of shove those things into into one
nomic phrase or clause and then it gets
a little complicated our viewers will
see on the screen unscathed by medieval
feudalism but then there's a long
parenthetical expression with its fixed
classes of aristocracy and for Locke
tugging peasants actually this is this
is a short parenthetical information
semicolon exempt from 19th century
Europe ideological power grabbing
fratricide stop there yeah explain a
little more of this well I'm well all of
us is condensed I don't I don't see this
as obscure certainly we never had the
fixed classes of European feudalism so
that that should be perfectly clear the
peasants and the aristocracy and and you
know that that tended to lead to too
violent revolutionary interactions and
we didn't have that kind of problem we
were all essentially middle class unless
there were of course there were some
slaves insofar as the the next thing the
whole 19th century ideological
fratricide there you had you know you
had pitched battles you had you had
you had political parties that resorted
to to to violent means you had you had
people taking over cities you had the
Paris Commune you had you had all of all
of this stuff and which people were
fighting to the death for political
programs and we had none of that we
avoided all of that hearing li9 stay in
the United States yet let me go back to
that so Nicole I'm going to read all the
way to the end of the easier thing
exempt from 19th century Europe's
ideological power grabbing fret resides
parentheses there by virtue of early
white male suffrage lots of land waves
of immigrants to assume the lousy
Estelle the native-born up early
mobilized themselves and a ragtag
diversity that undermined nascent class
consciousness while permitting the
merchants princelings to play workers of
different racial on ethnic backgrounds
against each other in a status scramble
closed parent and in insulated and
insulated from revolt revolting
developments insurgency in these jacker
ease by the way what's that jakhary is
goes back to the French Revolution and
that's a that's the a populist revolt
that that gets out of hand they start
they stop paying attention to the leader
it's essentially a mob but it be it
began as something supposedly better
than a mob
it needs jakhary even mud whomps and goo
Goo's what's a good google's good
government please to have those in new
york by a political city needs to be
liberal republicans were called goo
Goo's by a political system so partial
to the status quo it's almost
arteriosclerotic i want to take all
presidency fragmenting feudalism
federalism excuse me a bought judiciary
and a two-party incumbent protection
system there's a lot in that case yeah
there's there's a there's a lot but
let's be fair to me if you if you stop
it they stop it clause by clause but I'm
not complaining on I just want it's not
work it's not so it's not so obscure it
is it it's when you put them all
together as briefly in shorthand the way
I
it becomes gnarly but beyond beyond our
getting out of the out of the woods and
you have a limited amount of space to
essentially address a subject that
libraries have been written on so every
once in a while if you're me you take a
deep breath and say screw it I'm going
to have some fun I'm going to pile all
this in it will make sense if we if we
comb it out I'm going to make sure that
I put in enough so that the people who
really know this subject know that that
that I paid attention that I'm aware of
this factor I'm aware of feudalism and
I'm aware of the of the role of a
partisan political activity when it when
it it is allied with them with with
violence and and I'm going to take my
deep breath and I'm going to rush that
true and I'm going to get to the end of
it and I'm going to hope that I will be
forgiven because it will sound sort of
neat it will sound like like a fountain
or or a bunch of balloons going up or
fireworks or for whatever you know the
the real beginnings of the French
Revolution this isn't true but I like to
think it's true was was the hot air
balloon when they first developed the
wonderful hot-air balloons the king and
the aristocracy lost control of their
management of spectacle everybody could
look up everybody could enjoy it you
suddenly had crowds who could
participate in in in the excitement of
an event and they didn't have to have a
ticket
they didn't have to belong and once you
release that kind of excitement anything
would happen the barriers are down I had
the same feeling about writing sometimes
almost irrespective what the subject is
so I'm writing about socialism and this
is very serious stuff for their
passionate disputation on all sides on
this question I'm trying to summarize
why we were different and I just get
carried away war do you write I write at
home in a little office I've I've owned
a thirteen and a half foot wide
brownstone and they on the Upper East
Side of New York thirteen and a half
thirteen a half feet wide fifty feet
deep it's two rooms in a bathroom on
each floor that's a little garden out
back that's thirteen and a half feet
wide and 50 feet deep and there's a room
in the front it's been my office since
1971 Upper East Upper East Side 78 third
78th and second Avenue and I am I've
gone through I've gone through two of
behavioral revolutions the second one
yet to complete itself but if it if it
were that writing you know sixteen years
ago I almost died from booze and so I
had to give that up and I had good
advice from John Cheever before he died
it had to give up drinking and he said
that you know writers spend a lot of
time saying like you stop drinking and
you lose access to the unconscious and
all that flow of with all that stuff and
he says it's just none of that is true
this is he sober up since your writing
doesn't get any worse doesn't get any
better
this gets faster so breath he was right
three and half months ago I had to have
a Java 16 years ago sure now let's go
ahead to have I am a lung cancer
operation and there went there what the
cigarettes so I speak to you three and a
half months after this operation having
not put into my mouth and lungs 3176
cigarettes of a pack and a half a day so
I seem to be clean I seem to be alright
but I can never smoke again these have
effects when you sit in your little room
on a 78th Street looking at your that
you're at your computer screen as it is
now the effects are that you've booked
use a choreography to writing and I
write all the time and I bet I produce
an amazing amount of copy or always have
I'm not at the moment because I love it
it's where I get a kick out of just
writing reading and ready but but your
habits especially your bad habits are so
deeply ingrained that that it takes it
takes a much longer recovery process
than no longer needing alcohol the
longer wanting nicotine it takes a
recovery process of the whole your whole
performance style I don't know what to
do when I look at transitions now I
don't know if I could have written I
couldn't write now write that paragraph
you've been having wicked fun with
[Laughter]
because I would have had to sustained oh
and and revised and in order to sustain
a whole series of thoughts which which
had to be distinguished one from the
other which didn't arise naturally they
were they were not in a sequence that
went in a particular direction they all
spoke to the same subject and which had
to be made amusing or to sound musical
in the in the process and so this
it's a piece of this is what I love
doing but it's what I have great deal of
difficulty doing during these recovery
periods that one has as one as as one by
one one abandons one's license by the
way did you ever finish college no I'm a
drop out of Harvard and Berkeley and you
said you married twice
yes married what do you might do now I'm
married to a su Leonard who's a history
teacher at the Brearley school in New
York has been for almost a quarter of a
century
it's like Exeter and overts I once
kidded her it's better it's a wonderful
wonderful school but I used to kid her
that she taught internal contradictions
to the daughters of the ruling class and
they now had many more scholarship
students but the daughters of the ruling
class is still around how long I've been
married to her 25 years yeah why'd you
quit drinking
well cirrhosis and and also I seem to
have a related sort of attack of nerve
nerve damage from the left eye on
through the left arm or whatever
my father died an alcoholic you know at
age 44 and it alcoholism runs in runs in
families and especially runs in Irish
families and it was compounded by a
career in journalism I mean it's it's as
though it's a recipe and then it's still
my fault I did the drinking and I let
you but so they told me I had six months
to live it got my attention I got my
yeah what year did you quit drinking
1986 the smoking smoking you've had how
bad an operation was it well I always
said that if the if something showed up
on the chest x-ray you know then I had
to I had to take care of it and
something showed up so it was a
localized
what they first described as a spot so
it's not to scare the hell out of you
and then a growth or whatever so it was
localized in the right lung and looked
at it and took the cat scan and while
you don't know whether it's at that
point whether it's cancer or not it's
probably there's no point in doing
anything but going in there and having
it taken out and then finding that it's
nowhere else it's not in the lymph nodes
I mean everybody's got a different
cancer story and so they went in and
they took it out it seems to be gone and
I go back in for the checkup so that but
after that you know but it doesn't
matter how much I might like the
nicotine kick I had over three decades
of doing this that's yeah that's enough
are you going to continue to write focus
that's that's the way all I do
excellent you got a major book in you
you want to do no you know I gave up
writing novels a long time ago as I said
in one of the pieces in here when I
first when I really started reviewing
for the times and as you're doing books
like One Hundred Years of Solitude and
and you know and Toni Morrison and
Maxine Hong Kingston all these books and
Don DeLillo you say these people these
people really know what they want to do
with a long book I was writing I was
writing novels and I published four of
them because when I was brought up to be
a writer was to write novels that was
the definition but I had no burning
there's nothing I needed to communicate
by novel and I discovered a gift for
liking other people know for making
people want to read other people I want
to write a memoir like everybody else
but my memoir unlike what we've been
saying here is not about alcoholism and
nicotine addiction or whatever it's the
long march to the institutions I mean I
have worked for Buckley I work for the
nation I've worked for the New York
Times I work for CBS
I was I was first a television columnist
under a pseudonym for life meant the old
Life magazine before it died for
people's sins of work for Newsweek you
know I want to I want to put all that
down and see if it makes any sense
here's the cover of the book we didn't
get to an awful lot that's in this book
although some of them some of your own
lighters in here Lonesome Rangers is the
title this our guest has been John
Leonard you can see on CBS Sunday
morning doing television frozen thank
you thank you for having me